salut aujourd'hui je vais vous apprendre
à ne plus jamais perdre au jeu le plus
célèbre le morpion ce qui est bien c'est
qu'il ya plusieurs techniques existent
pour ça qu'elles sont faciles à retenir
est que même si quelqu'un d'autre
connaissez technique vous pouvez quand
même lutté pour au moins faire le match
nul et regardez bien jusqu'au bout de la
vidéo parce que même si vous croyez
connaître le morpion il ya des variantes
qui sont vraiment intéressant c'est
parti générique
qu'est ce qu'il fait là le coussin
[Musique]
dans le morpion de base autrement appelé
le tic-tac tout vous devez aligner trois
symboles identiques donc trois cercles
ou trois croient en tout début de partie
on détermine aléatoirement quel est le
joueur qui va commencer et c'est là que
tout commence
soit vous allez jouer en premier soit
vous allez jouer en deuxième et on va
appliquer une stratégie qui va faire que
vous allez soit gagnée soit au moins
réussir à créer un match nul donc vous
ne perdrez jamais vous allez voir c'est
très simple à comprendre si vous êtes le
joueur numéro 1 le joueur qui commence
alors commencez toujours par jouer dans
un angle peu importe la réponse de
l'autre joueur ou est ce qui mettra son
cercle
vous allez jouer votre deuxième coup sur
la même ligne en faisant ça et en jouant
normalement derrière vous allez créer
une situation où un moment donné vous
allez avoir deux possibilités de gagner
alors que votre adversaire ne peut
contrer qu'une seule possibilité donc
vous aurez gagné qu'un seul cas où ça ne
fonctionnera pas c'est quand
l'adversaire mais son premier coup au
centre dans ces cas là vous appliquer la
même méthode 1 vous vous continuez la
même ligne puis vous jouer normalement
jusqu'au bout et vous allez créer un
match nul maintenant deuxième cas de
figure c'est l'adversaire qui commence
donc vous êtes le joueur numéro deux il
ya trois possibilités soit il commence
dans un coin auquel cas vous vous jouez
au centre puis vous jouer normalement et
vous allez créer un match nul soit lui a
commencé au centre et dans ce cas là
vous vous mettez dans un coin et vous
allez créer aussi un match nul en
continuant de bloquer votre adversaire à
chaque coup et la troisième possibilité
celle ci comment celui sur un bord dans
ce cas là vous vous mettez votre premier
coup au centre et c'est le seul cas où
en commençant deuxième vous avez une
possibilité de gagner près il ya un
autre cas c'est si l'adversaire fait une
erreur en mémorisant ça vous ne perdrez
plus jamais au morpion les seule chose à
retenir c'est que si vous êtes le avoue
commencer dans un angle et vous
continuez à la ligne
si vous êtes le 2 vous commencez au
centre puis vous bloquez et s'il a
commencé au centre vous jouez dans un
coin et vous bloquez la tactique est
aussi simple que ça et du coup le jeu
est aussi simple que ça c'est pour ça
qu'il existe des variations qui sont
extrêmement intéressants que la première
daria sion c'est le mental tic tac tout
c'est le même jeu la même chose mais on
le joue mentalement il n'y a pas de
support papier alors au départ les
joueurs doivent se mettre d'accord sur
une numérotation par exemple les
colonnes de la gauche vers la droite
sont abaissés et les lignes de autant
basson 1 2 3 ce qui fait que le premier
joueur dit par exemple je vais placer
mon premier en b2c une manière de jouer
qui est très sympa parce que déjà elle
elle est plus compliquée elle autorise
l'erreur des joueurs c'est plus
compliqué de voir tout ce qui se passe
en même temps et en plus de ça ça fait
travailler votre visualisation interne
personnellement j'y joue que comme ça et
j'aime bien parce qu'on n'a pas besoin
de papier ou de crayon une autre manière
d'y jouer c'est de jouer au gault
beaucoup alors je dis go beaucoup
peut-être que ça se dit guo q mais ça
sonne tout de suite différemment le goût
beaucoup ça se joue avec un tableau de
19 lignes sur dix neuf colonnes et on ne
va jouer que sur les intersections comme
dans le jeu de groupe d'ailleurs 10 9
sur 19 c'est le jeu de go ce qui nous
fait un total je suis persuadé que vous
l'aviez déjà compté 2 360 et une
intersection alors on y joue avec des
pions en général si on utilise le jeu de
go on a les pions blancs et noirs
et on donne pas 180 pion à chacun on
donne juste soixante pion à chacun ça se
joue comme au morpion normal je vous le
dis sauf qu'on joue sur les
intersections et le premier qui arrive à
faire cinq pions d'affilée en ligne en
colonne ou en diagonale remporte la
partie et on n'est pas obligé de faire
dix neuf lignes sur 19 lignes on peut
faire qu'un sur 15 par exemple c'est
sûrement la manière la plus intéressante
de jouer au morpion
et après si vous êtes des tueurs vous
pouvez essayer de jouer cette version là
mentalement personnellement j'ai jamais
essayé je vous avais promis qu'on ferait
cette vidéo bientôt ben voilà ça c'est
fait la prochaine vidéo elle va porter
sur la solution de l'énigme
je vous le dis j'ai déjà les 100
personnes j'ai déjà les 100 gagnants qui
vont être tyrosse
mais après vous pouvez toujours la
résoudre pour vous le vrai le challenge
d'une énigme c'est pas les gains c'est
le plaisir de réussir à la résoudre
j'essaierai de sortir cette vidéo en fin
de semaine puisque demain je repars en
tournée je mette à rouen durant trois
jours
je vous rappelle rapidement qu'ils
risquent six dates de tournée one nice
la suisse conflans sainte honorine moret
sur loing et nantes est également dans
quelques jours la sortie de mon livre
que vous pouvez déjà pré commander sur
amazon la fnac ou chez votre libraire
préféré et je voulais dire un petit
message aux 467 1244 abonnés oui ça a
encore augmenté depuis la dernière vidéo
merci vous avez littéralement détruit la
dernière barre de like sur la vidéo
précédente par rapport à la story je
crois même qu'on va atteindre l'objectif
plutôt prévu mais en tout cas ses amis
la vidéo dans les tendances donc merci
pour ça n'hésitez pas si vous voulez
vous faire plaisir zèle si vous pouvez
l'acheter à like vous abonner à très
bientôt ciao
[Musique]